c'est l'histoire d'un père qui n'a pas
été beaucoup là qui reçoit un jour un
coup de fil on lui dit il faut que tu
rentre tout de suite ton fils a été
enlevé c'est un homme civilisé qui
plonge dans des choses terribles qui
font que il devient un animal c'est un
vrai chien de chasse il essaye de savoir
de comprendre ce qui s'est passé ça
faisait très longtemps qu'on parlait de
ce projet avec christian on a discuté
d'un concept faut très vite j'ai eu
envie de proposer avec guillaume canet
de se mettre finalement dans la peau du
personnage julie voilà guillaume c'est
un mec qui sait rien est-ce que tu
acceptes de faire un film sans rien
seulement met ici on fait le film de
cette manière là ce sera sans scénario
moi j'avais rien le droit de savoir
l'âge parle avec personne ne soit
rachetée dans un hôtel à part tout seul
les étés rentrer les techniciens n'ai
pas à me parler j'arrive devant cette
baraque et paumé d'emplois dans la neige
j'approche tout seul puis la joue un mec
sortir un tas de bois et cas avec une
caméra puis j'ai toujours la voix de
christian derrière monte escalier on est
dans le noir via le cadreur qui est
derrière on sait pas ce qui va se passer
je suis complètement dans un état que je
ne peux pas trouver en tant qu'acteur et
c'est comme ça tout le temps quoi mais
surprise que j'ai eue pendant le film
c'était dingue on a l'impression de
vivre complètement la situation c'est
des scènes qui sont fortes je m'en
remets toujours pas ça à chaque fois que
j'en parle à quelqu'un et des frissons
de repenser à ce que j'ai vécu en fait
en tant qu'acteur suite j'ai bien senti
ça et pour ça c'était une expérience
extraordinaire